and biden is just standing there and
saying yeah just invade yeah i think
that the u.s president no u.s president
is probably responsible for getting us
into war these days i think it's more
deep state and like administrative
officials that are pulling the strings
but a president seems to be able to stop
it from happening but at least put the
brakes on
keep my look everything's interconnected
so she watching this is looking saying
hey taiwan you look pretty juicy that's
the one where i do think i think that
she i don't know how long after the
olympics he goes and makes his move
that's the one where i think putin goes
and takes a little part of ukraine
chalks up a victory he gets his win uh
he stops the nato expansion uh into uh
uh or the eu expansion pardon me into
ukraine some of the other things but i
do think she goes all the way and goes
for taiwan what gets me this invasion of
iraq and afghanistan the united's pulled
off the united states pulled off i can't
in good in good like conscience
say hey china don't invade taiwan
because it's like dude i just supported
a country for 20 years that invaded a
country and still in iraq so
but at the same time i can't condone
to ccp invading taiwan i can't condone i
think the people in ukraine got a very
tough lesson in american foreign policy
when they saw what happened in
afghanistan so i i feel bad for the
people of ukraine they're in an
extremely tough situation on one side
you have russia on another side you have
nato and joe biden who pulled off one of
the worst withdrawals
literally arming our enemies literally
if you couldn't pull off a worse move
than you could even try to when it came
to what biden did with afghanistan and
that's still fresh in a lot of people's
minds especially internationally
especially in ukraine who are sitting
there like man we're screwed well let me
ask this though some people have pointed
out in the chat
if russia moves on ukraine
china goes for taiwan instantly what do
you think possibility yeah i think it's
uh and look the order could be the other
way around but there's there's always
safety in numbers that make it two-front
war because then you have nato you have
apac you have that um
you have everyone who's looking at so i
think that's probably uh that's probably
pretty accurate although i think i do
think that both happen uh regardless but
it speeds up and expedites the action of
such uh if they both do it or what if
one does it yeah let's say
this year
russia invades ukraine it seems like
it's likely i mean or at the very least
the u.s is saying that there will be a
false flag or something happens let's
say that china does move on taiwan what
do you think the bud administration's
response is going to be you think
they'll be able to handle this or do you
think it just falls apart i think it
falls apart and i tell you the other
thing too just especially as i'm
traveling around and push the platform
and a lot of different countries
japan is freaked the heck out japan is
looking out and saying hey if they take
taiwan we're next oh yeah and they are
the entire region is absolutely in panic
saying
at least again you know we knew where
things were with trump but biden we saw
his response tonight he talked like a
u.s senator he said i'm going to give
them the toughest sanctions they're
going to be they're on restriction they
do not get to ride their bike for two
weeks uh and it's that's about how tough
it was this is why american foreign
policy is so mind-boggling because it's
self-defeating it's shooting itself in
the foot you have a situation where
russia and china don't like each other
there's an opportunity to work with one
another have peaceful cooperation have
economic
incentives to work with europe and the
more that the united states puts up
these neoconservatives the more we push
push away russia the more russia becomes
closer to china and they could act in
unison and strategically that would be
the move that they would pull off that
would put the united states in a very
particularly difficult position on the
world stage that wouldn't only just
question its hegemony but alt-right
changed the whole understanding of how
the world kind of operates so this is
this could also be a deliberate effort
to bring down the united states with
this kind of viewpoint of what the world
sees america as especially under biden
there's no way the u.s can maintain its
its empire there's no way it can
maintain the military bases everywhere
that russia moves on ukraine we're split
on two fronts the us does not have the
organizational power does not have the
cohesion we've got viral videos of you
know women in the army doing tick tock
dances we've got wokeness and critical
race theory
i gotta be honest if xi jinping is
looking at taiwan he's probably laughing
about what he sees in the u.s media
having to do with our military vladimir
putin the same thing there was that
viral campaign where the russian
military ad of it's all black and it's
all gray and green and there's this guy
and he's all sweating he's ripped and
he's doing push-ups and he jumps out of
a plane and he lands he's got the mask
on his arms and he's like uh he's
fighting and then you have the um the us
army ad of a little girl saying i have
two moms
and i'm like that's cool i guess i don't
know how that's gonna instill fear in
our adversaries and the people who want
to do wrong by us and our friends
but i guess
this is what we end up with yeah
something tells me that she and putin do
not sit around debating whether or not
they're going to fund transgender
surgeries that's that's probably not
something that they spend much time on i
want to make sure i'm being fair too at
the same time as this ad comes out and
everyone criticized the army ad for
having this like woke diversity thing we
still have the marine corps which is
putting out ads of like there's one
where a guy he sees like weird
futuristic sci-fi hologram selling
sneakers and then he like swings at one
and then falls and slams and also he's
in a swamp and he gets up and he's armed
and it's the marine corps and it's much
much more hardcore much more similar to
the russian ad so
that's a fair point i want to make sure
there's we're giving the reasonableness
the rationality here but um
i don't think russia is putting together
ads to convince their military service
member in any branch
to be woke diverse
comfy cuddly pastel bean bags safety
spaces and all that stuff
so unfortunately for us
or maybe even you know there's still a
light at the end of the tunnel maybe we
shouldn't be the world police maybe we
we never wanted to be donald trump was
very critical of of this aspect of
america and maybe this will
you know get us back to america first
policies make us focus on our own
borders maybe biden's failures will cost
us our empirical status in a sense but
we'll end up with a stronger economy at
home with the working class being you
know better supported with secure
borders
but we know that's not going to happen
we know that especially not under biden
at least not till we get another
a different president in the white house
i mean the fact of the matter is trump
had this very much disposition the
america first uh and look a lot of
criticism a lot of heat from people
saying you should be doing things to
help out obviously he sent the um uh
military the missiles to ukraine but
said you got to go and handle it on your
own but people knew where trump stood
and so with north korea that was when he
put through the big economic sanctions
on china so he had that approach
he was aggressive he was out in front on
a number of these things the thing with
biden is i don't even think biden knows
what his strategy is he's oh we're going
to go and you know we'll talk we'll have
some different things and it's he's not
making friends with anything he's
basically just sending the the signal to
everyone that we're weak americans were
weak and that's when things especially
as i've been traveling around even like
i said we're talking about this before
we started even the countries where
people trump was way upside down he's
like 10 favorable they're saying at
least with trump people wouldn't
steamroll the us or the us's allies
biden is inviting all of the aggression
from she and putin because he's so weak
i mean it was that was a disgrace to the
country what we saw in that two-hour
press conference that he had tonight
it's embarrassing but that's just who
joe biden is
my i tweeted out that's our joe
because we know it it you know i was
watching uh uh we were i remember what
we were watching earlier but i saw a
commercial for jimmy kimmel
and i just looked up and i said
everybody you know it's crazy that there
are people who still live in that world
that fake media handcrafted narrative
world people still live in there it's
the matrix
you know i guess i can envy those
poor ignorant fools but ignorance is
bliss so that bliss i mean sounds great
turn on the tv joe biden's great he's
charismatic and confident everything's
better than ever and for those of us
that have taken that red pill and popped
out of the matrix we're like wow this is
really bad but i'll tell you what at
least we can buy our emergency food and
build our bunkers so that when it does
hit the fan we'll be okay for at least a
few months right i'm kidding calm down
everybody i don't think it's a bombastic
statement to say that the american
empire is going down and that there are
special interests in this country that
are making sure that it gets destroyed
from the inside and i think one way they
will do that is by of course
creating more afghanistan situations
creating more foreign policy failures
creating more foreign policy that
absolutely lets the entire world down
it's absolutely crazy to act and play
like this tough guy when again diplomacy
is the biggest strength that you could
show if you could resolve problems
without needing to saber-rat or or start
a war or kill people that's one of the
biggest strengths that you could have on
this world and and
you know more than ever we need
diplomats but but now we have a
situation that is very very dangerous
and only going to be expanding from here
and uh i think the united states is
being destroyed deliberately and i think
foreign policy
is a major ingredient to that
destruction and i just add on that is
that the only way that diplomacy works
is if they think that you have the
fortitude to back it up or if they think
that you're tough and new because i
agree with you i look i i don't want us
to go sending more troops over to europe
or to asia to anywhere else i mean it's
i thought it was good what trump did
with drawing troops from a number of the
countries from around the world but if
people don't think that you actually act
or back up any of your allies on this
then they're gonna go and they're gonna
be aggressive and then guess what's
gonna happen then you get to real war
i think we're headed towards real war
i mean at least
we've
with what china's been doing you know we
we have them going near our waters in
hawaii going near our waters in alaska
we've had that that meeting with anthony
blinken where china basically just said
the united states is not coming from a
position of power
so when we're at that you know we can
call it thucydides trap maybe the simple
way to put it is not any special kind of
you know named
idea it's just that china is growing in
power and as their power grows and their
military might grows they become more
confident and they start looking in
america saying you know what we're not
we're not shorter than you anymore we've
grown up we've matured and we're
powerful screw you and the u.s being the
old dog gonna be like no way but we got
joe biden
so we can't keep in mind that russia and
china both have similar uh issues that
they're facing where putin and xi have
to watch their flank internally as well
part of the reason why putin does the
whole saber rattling is because that's a
strategy of saying you know what i want
to shore up my domestic base by going
get everyone focused on the fact that
ukraine is we own ukraine these terrible
horrible people from the west are trying
to impose on us so you know let's pay
attention to that as opposed to the fact
that russia's economy is the size of the
state of new york she one of the things
china's economy is in real tough stretch
right now they have this massive water
crisis in china that is the real deal i
mean it is they have some real problems
and their thing too all the cheap labor
force that they have everyone's moving
up to the middle class in china so they
can't pay people like two pennies an
hour they're having to go and try to
essentially pillage vietnam and other
countries to do this so she has the same
issue that's part of the reason why he
has to go and move on taiwan to go shore
up his base get her own rallied say it's
us against the west again yeah and they
have also very little natural resources
very limited ability to farm and produce
food this is why china is trying to turn
a desert into farmland right now this is
the the lengths that they're turning to
they also turned to wet weather
modification trying to alter climates in
order to provide better farming
situations because this is why it's so
important for them to move out of that
landlocked position strategically this
is why they've been building islands
this is why even taiwan is is so
tempting for them because they know they
need to expand their empire if they
don't they're going to be doomed
especially with the population that they
have right now filled with a lot of men
and very little women and that you know
the situation in china is like a perfect
storm a perfect recipe of disaster well
you know to tim to your point about
their aggression even doing things all
the way to hawaii i mean since when did
nine dash line extend to maui right i
mean but that's basically where they are
now they're like hey this is the um the
decoupling is happening what's the worst
case scenario for us though i mean
if china starts expanding and taking
over i know there's economic
consequences so from a really crass
perspective there are a couple things
number one it basically says
if you're if they go and take because
you don't take part of taiwan right it's
an island so either go and take the
whole thing it's a sovereign country
it's not like ukraine where you can
carve out a few miles and say we declare
victory and uh you know we we we stop
the expansion of the eu and all this
kind of stuff
taiwan is different from a couple things
one it's a country where we have drawn a
line is the u.s and said this is an ally
we're immediately signaling we'll do
nothing for japan or anyone else in the
region the other thing too and again
this is very crass but it's you know the
real world the fact that if uh china
were to take taiwan
the world semiconductor market is we are
beyond screwed we have sent everything
to taiwan the us i don't think people
realize if they china will then own
effectively everything and i know that's
that's i'm just being very crass about
it but it's saying that the the west
will never defend an ally just as much
right right right uh cars already hard
to come by computers
and it's not just that we put computer
chips in everything and that's taiwan uh
steve bannon was talking about he said
silicon valley west and that's why
you've got u.s interests desperately
trying to pump government money into
american factories to produce chips
silicone chips semiconductors etc
because we know what's coming and i i i
appreciate the effort but it also kind
of feels like their their quick and
desperate moves into funding american
manufacturing in this you know space
while a good thing just signals we
expect taiwan to fall to china
it's a matter of when not if yeah that's
what china says china officially stated
on the record it's not when we invade
taiwan it's it's no no it's not if we
it's sorry sorry yeah yeah it's not if
we invade taiwan it's one thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm now
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you